[Música]
devo confessar que desde que era criança
tenha o sonho de pisar um palco externo
e desde então tem trabalhado pela quando
eu era criança no ensino técnico e não o
que só pode significar uma coisa eu era
criança queria participar no teto não
existia até portanto eu sou o inventor
do terra
e tenha que viajar a primeira grande
revelação deste ano
ora ponte é um tema apropriado para o
técnico português porque a ponte é um
tema que normalmente é do interesse
masculino os homens entre essas mais por
construção civil importante dar este
título uma conferência é em si uma ponte
o equivalente a criarmos um término do
iguaçu em correntes só teve sobre o
verniz ou sapato mas eu queria passar
já a segunda grande revelação que vai
senhoras têm de aprender a dominar algo
que vai fazer de jeito
o meu dado como é óbvio seria pouco meu
da minha parte eu tentar estão ser este
ensinamento da perspectiva de um homem
não é por isso que estou aqui
eu queria dar voz a uma mulher conhecida
por acaso e creio que a sua história
merece ser contada essa mulher era feliz
era casada e tinha dois filhos
lourenço e evita não trabalhava e tem
como especialidade culinária um arroz de
lingueirão que não ficava atrás das
receitas do doutor ávila e se sente um
dia estava meio de uma lavagem de louça
e certas perguntas que nunca tinha feito
a si própria começaram a brotar da sua
cabeça
quem sou eu pra onde vou o que quer ser
e sabem que mais
ela respondeu que sim
as questões ora o marido
vendo a sua angústia ainda devolveu o
cartão cidadão ia dizer isto e tentou
usar da sua sabedoria masculina
apresentar ao jornal a responder ao as
restantes questões mas ela interrompeu
revirou os olhos encontrou dispara um
homem nunca vai saber como é que um
cinto para fazer - planning
para quem não sabe o que é - spanning eu
vou explicar muito devagar é uma das
palavras favoritas das feministas e
acontece quando um homem explica aldo
mulher que ela já sabe
num tom condescendente nós já estamos a
caminhar para uma sociedade um dos
homens já não podem explicar nada as
mulheres no fundo basicamente o que as
feministas não estão a dizer é que já
não tem nada a aprender com os homens
voltamos à história o homem não estou
decepcionado e fez o normal nestas
situações
pediu o divórcio num primeiro instante
ela sente desamparada não é não tinha
casa não tinha trabalho
o marido cortou lhe o cartão de crédito
a gasolina e ela chorou e este poderia
ser um momento em que ela mostraria
arrependimento e voltei pro marido
depois de desculpa mas não fez
por orgulho orgulho esse que puxou para
raiva e é precisamente na raiva que
vivem sunitas
ela tornou se numa deixou de fazer a
depilação e começou a defender que as
mulheres são iguais aos homens
um aparte sobre depilação
as feministas dizem que as mulheres só
se depilam para agradar aos homens é um
dos pratos
as mulheres não fazem pelos homens fazem
por elas porque se não o fizerem se
mantiverem os pêlos todos as pernas e no
busto
os homens não vão querer nada com elas
a entrada eu eu mais tarde quando
encontrar com deus eu vou perguntar
porque é que eu crio as mulheres com
pelos nossos primos depiladas
provavelmente vai responder um banho que
o fez perder minimizar a economia e para
criar um incentivo para as minhas
clientes de artistas é uma excelente
resposta e eu não estava à espera de
outra coisa da parte de deus deus também
nos criou sem roupa porque para
dinamizar a indústria têxtil
o que quer dizer qo pelo é nossa roupa
dá origem a partir do momento que a
roupa não precisamos pelo olympique
função tendencialmente os homens foram
por exemplo pelo o que quer dizer que a
longo prazo
deus deve ter como plano tornarmos uma
espécie totalmente desvinculada da
função é primeiras deleta história ao
incentivarem as mulheres a manterem suas
pílulas cidades acionistas o que estão a
fazer é aproximá las de seus pré
históricos de animais em relação aos
pêlos púbicos resolver toda a gente está
com essa pergunta na nossa cara
a resposta é muito simples as mulheres
devem pilares e os homens não por uma
questão de cavalheirismo
sim senhoras gostam do meio do rosto
surge ao que surpreenda sim hora a
senhora desta história deixou pilar está
lúcido e atingiu a tão desejada
igualdade
curiosamente estava mais influentes do
que nunca a trans ou totalmente a ponte
e tornou se um homem e esta sua nova fé
foi abalada em dois momentos
num primeiro momento ela estava a passar
enfrenta uma sapataria e sentiu se
atraída por um sapato que faziam lembrar
uma vida passada então olhou para baixo
e ver os meus própios são tão
confortáveis porque eu prefiro o salto
alto e salto alto é um produto de moda
que estabelece um padrão de beleza para
dar aos jovens para que eu quero agradar
aos homens
a resposta vai no segundo momento depois
de uma semana sem pilar reparou que
ninguém reparava nela e começou a sentir
falta de comentários depreciativos de
desconhecidos na rua
ora as feministas criticam os homens por
fazerem aqui o vulgarmente se chama
cumprir o que dizem que a marcação e é o
pior pode ser excessivo pode ser
despropositados pode ser até
intimidatório
mas é necessário pôr em algum lugar dos
homens que fazem pilotos
eu só estava tentará aumentar a
autoestima das mulheres
não não pretendem agredir o próprio
presidente dos estados unidos
costumava abordar as mulheres de forma
pouco convencional mas porque era uma
estrela ela deixava se fossem homens
quando eram abordados pelo autor kevin
spacey mas
ao serem abordados por estrelas as
mulheres sabiam qual era o seu valor no
mercado
eu sou a favor do mercado livre em todas
as áreas
a quantidade de pilotos que uma pessoa
recebe é um excelente indicador
quantitativo do seu valor de mercado é
uma agência de rating do desejo como é
que não sabemos se somos bem cotados no
mercado da atração sexual sem pilotos
criminalizar o piropo é dar um subsídio
às pessoas faz para que nos falam mal
celso uma mulher que vive uma mulher
bonita que é agredida verbalmente também
o é para dizer às pessoas faz que são
falhas por omissão não precisam ter
inveja esforça e se mais não é ter esta
atitude não apenas para mim não aprendem
ganhar não é assim que funciona em vista
um fácil subir o valor do mercado faça
uma limpeza papel uma operação plástica
o deixem sair à rua e comuniquem só
através das redes sociais onde as
pessoas só conhecem pelas vossas fotos e
perfil mais favoráveis sem piropo não há
incentivo para as pessoas se tornarem
mais atraentes
nem vamos marcar tudo por baixo
isso é péssimo para o turismo
[Música]
ora podemos dizer que com a ausência
piloto foi um momento eureka da senhora
da nossa história porque ela de pilotos
e voltou para o marido
ela entretanto já se tenha voltado a
casar mas aceitou de volta como amante
em nome dos bons velhos tempos e ela diz
descumprido as feministas falam em
perpetuar estereótipos como se fosse
negativo não é periódico é uma forma de
garantir que as pessoas se comportam de
forma normal e que se comportam como a
sociedade espera
saem preto sem preconceito teremos uma
sociedade imprevisível e insegura
os preconceitos são uma forma nós
colocarmos as pessoas em caixas de modo
a que seja mais fácil lidar com elas em
previsibilidade é um risco que não
podemos correr
é isso que nos distingue dos animais
esta é que é a realidade
evito isto o marido respondeu à crise e
isso é muito interessante mas podia
falar um bocadinho menos eles não posso
falar muito eu sou chata para encaixar
no preconceito no estereótipo do que são
as mulheres e por isso vou continuar a
falar embora tanto o marido foi ver
futebol e deixou a falar sozinho e eu
não vou mostrar mais com essa história
porque vocês já sabem conexão isso nunca
mais 100 anos aqui
ora o que é que a senhora desta história
aprendeu perdeu uma preciosa lição
as mulheres não podem ser mais do que
aquilo que são a opção já está lenta não
podem virar os olhos sempre que o homem
tenta fazer - planning and planning é
forma de um homem transmitir
conhecimento as mulheres conhecimento
esse que nos têm dado vantagem sobre as
mulheres ao longo de milhares de anos
se um homem está o trabalho de explicar
alguma mulher
venho
é porque ela se torna um ser humano mais
competente
já nós homens não queremos que as
mulheres não explica nada porque
queremos que ela continue a fazer aquilo
que sempre fizeram
cada um no seu lugar este é o drama do
feminismo
esse é o grande drama pelos acionistas
querem que as mulheres sejam homens e
mulheres ao mesmo tempo
quando uma mulher se emancipa e vai
tentar arranjar emprego acaba por
trabalhar o dobro porque vai fazer o
trabalho do homem mas as tarefas todas
que ela tem que fazer nós homens temos
todo o gosto em proteger as mulheres
terem tomar decisões difíceis como se os
grandes empresas
temos todo o gosto em protegê las da
história moda que todas as acusações
sobre ditadores caíram só ser homens
hitler estaline tony carreira e queremos
protegê las de não terem de lidar com a
forma pinhal que deus nos forneceu
entanto os gostos associados não é na
mulher foi só instalado um vulgar
recipiente uma porta usb de semana
dito isto criar pontes e aceitar a
desigualdade entre homens e mulheres
pensei na cidade do porto e gaia estamos
a falar de uma cidade bonita cortou está
unida ao senado viveu e não foi preciso
gastar sempre a chegar à que foi
construída a ponto o porto construiu a
ponte de forma altruísta e se pensam que
esta lição de pontos pode aprender numa
escola de engenharia não pode vai na
bíblia deus foi o primeiro a construir
uma ponte quando dirigiu na pélvis do
douradão 11 peles
cabul o homem estender a ponta mulher e
cabos a vocês
assim que aceitarem ser humilde atrasar
essa ponte será estendida como homem tem
todo o gosto em estender a minha ponte
sempre que caíram
obrigado
[Aplausos]